Last night's State of the Union
was an irrefutable disaster.
Is the President going
to drop out of the race?
Congress truly is in a sorry, sorry state.
The system is broken!
And you people broke it!
Well, I really screwed that up, didn't I?
Each one of you has been with
me from the beginning of this ride.
So, I need your opinion.
If you run and if you lose...
that's your legacy.
I think you're asking the wrong thing.
The question should be:
"Why am I running in the first place?"
Our President is not embracing all of us
as American citizens.
I don't feel like anybody represents me.
You're concerned about making
the wrong decisions.
Any leader worth a damn would be.
It makes sense to be angry.
Angry like all of you are!
Hell, I am with you!
Keep showing the voters who you really are
and the rest will take care of itself.
Think about whether you'd like to join
the ticket as Kirkman's Vice President.
Why would you keep this to yourself?
What the hell were you thinking?
Whatever happened to standards?
What happened to ethical practices?
So, everyone has the right to privacy
except when it's convenient for you?
This isn't journalism!
Why aren't you mad?
I know the truth.
How would you like to come
work for the C.I.A.?
There's been an outbreak in Toronto.
We need to make contact before
an unfriendly does.
We have to be prepared for the possibility
of a vile terrorist attack.
What's your call, Mr. President?
I am guessing here.
You may not have what it takes to win.
Because what it takes is ruthlessness.
You want me to march around
the White House
picking fights with the President?
You're a coward.
You took away my right to choose.
I'm sorry that I lied.
Lynn?
I need an ambulance right away.
Oh, my God.
I've gone all in for what I think
is right for the heart of this country.
You hold yourself above politics!
The truth is, you're every bit
as much a politician as I am.
God help me if that's true.